aside from all the weird aliens roguish
bounty hunters and thrilling action
sequences one thing Disney's flagship
series the Mandalorian has in common
with the Star Wars saga is that as
chock-full of subtle references and
callbacks to other Star Wars media here
are a few you may have missed as you'd
hope from any decent Star Wars story the
Mandalorian features all kinds of
different alien races and cultures take
that first bar scene for example during
this scene a fearsome looking man with
an unruly beard beats up on a blue
skinned my thrall the bounty the
Mandalorian is after the guy then tries
to pick a fight with the Mandalorian
himself geez be Bahasa be ogre but
here's a bonus for you the language he's
speaking is Huttese the language of the
Hertz which is used most notably by Java
and Return of the Jedi
[Music]
after the Mandalorian captures in cars
optimized role to collect the price on
his head the prisoner makes small talk
with the stoic silent bounty hunter back
on his ship yeah I was hoping to be free
for a life day so what's life day well
it's the Star Wars universe his
equivalent of Christmas a time for
celebrating and relaxing with loved ones
it was first introduced in the Star Wars
Holiday Special
an infamous Star Wars scene television
variety show the special follows
Chewbacca's family as they watch
futuristic TV and wait for him to arrive
for life day but even ends with Princess
Leia singing a life de carril life day
isn't the only Mandalorian call back to
that unloved Star Wars Holiday Special
the show's protagonist also supports the
distinctive weapon that should be
familiar to longtime fans of a galaxy
far far away it's a cool-looking
apparatus with a heck of a past in Boba
Fett's first ever appearance during an
animated sequence in the holiday special
he's packing the same weapon it likely
doesn't mean much as far as a connection
to Fett is concerned but it's a nifty
nod to Star Wars law that proves her
jon favreau is deeply invested in
layering fanservice into his series
early on in the episode when the
mandalorian anna's finn faced bounty a
booking passage back to his ship they
encounter an alien hidden behind a pair
of goggles and the long snout he plays a
killer flute and his name is never
revealed but he should have been
instantly recognizable to any
detail-oriented Star Wars fan this fella
is a Kubas an alien species who's only
shown up on one other time over the
course of the Star Wars saga cast your
mind back to a new hope specifically the
scene shortly after Luke and obi-wan
meet han Solo and Chewbacca in the
alleyways of Mos Eisley a Kubas named
Garen dan contacts the Imperial
Stormtroopers patrolling the streets to
let them know that he's found that
droids they're looking for while it's
pretty unlikely that this guy will show
up in any other episodes of the
Mandalorian it's still a pretty cool
deep curtain to the galaxy's expansive
mythos of course it goes without saying
that the Mandalorian is full to the brim
of droids in one particular sequence the
Mandalorian walks through a marketplace
one of the objects he walked by is some
kind of red and white r5 droid which
looks an awful lot like that red and
white r5 d4 drone from a new hope you
know the one with the bad motivator yeah
this r2 unit has a bad motivator look
when the Mandalorian arrives at the
fortified headquarters of the clients
he's also greeted by a round red light
equipped droid tasked with security and
gatekeeping tasks and sure enough for
that little fella looks just like the
security droid Jabba the Hutt had
installed on the front gate of his
palace in Return of the Jedi in the
Mandalorian times seemed to be
especially tough for the Empire and as
many underlings for example the man
initially known as the client appears to
be an ex Imperial something he's not
exactly afraid to flaunt as he surrounds
himself with a squad of those familiar
white armored stormtroopers they're
still pretty formidable looking but
they've clearly fallen on hard times
since the end of the empire reflected by
the fact that their outfits are well
worn a bit dirty and even cracked in
some parts perpetually master bounty
hunter Boba Fett's is probably one of
the most treasured characters and all of
Star Wars but he's actually not the
Mandalorian in fact he sought a
Mandalorian at all confused
luckily the show-up he is set to teach
casual Star Wars fans and those
more about the Mandalorians as a culture
not much is revealed in that first
episode but the protagonist does venture
into some sort of special forge in order
to upgrade his armor carrying a Slav of
bhaskar steel that he acquired from the
client he descends into an area where
numerous other Mandalorians are shown
including one shadowy figure in the
background who looks suspiciously like
the long-dead Boba Fett's it's also in
this scene that the show offers a few
brief glimpses into the Mandalorians
past specifically the attack that
orphaned him as a boy and left him a
foundling the Mandalorian term for an
orphan the forger who makes his new
pauldron mentioned that the leftover
scrap will be used to sponsor other
foundlings the audience's first clue
that in addition to being a fearsome
bounty hunter this character may also be
pursuing a nobler agenda until now the
kawaki and monkey lizard has had just
one place in star wars canon as the
snickering pet of and savory characters
like Jabba the Hutt's their mischief
first they're obnoxious they seem
well-suited for villainy and apparently
they're delicious
immediately after the Mandalorian gets
his bounty assignment from the clients
he walks through the marketplace of a
desolate looking little town in which
one familiar alien species stands out
sucks for him too because he's being
spit roasted while his horrified buddy
looks on honestly this is a fairly
horrific moment especially when you
remember that these animals are
intelligent enough to have a pretty
well-developed sense of humor but hey
that's the outer rim for you check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]